[Music]
they're pulling out all the stops in
georgia
and these are the voters who could swing
it but look at the security they feel
they need
just to vote you never know when the
attack is going to come
you never know who there is frantic work
to get the black vote out
yes in a state where the polls show the
candidates tantalisingly close
abide in victory here would likely doom
the president's re-election bid
black voters are tapering off so we need
to really make a final push a hard push
right
for the first time in decades georgia is
a battleground state
and the young have energized it all
right let's go get this worked let's
do it but their arrival on the campaign
trail
isn't always welcomed he just told us to
get the elf out of his neighborhood
do you feel intimidated when something
like that happens i don't
you feel worried i don't angry i don't
what do you feel strength
georgia is historically a red state now
the democrats are on the cusp of turning
it blue
but they're racing to get the
disillusioned out voting
i can't keep following a trend that was
set up
from past oppressions you get what i'm
saying so you're not going to vote
right so i i
three tacos they've been record numbers
voting
early amid claims the long lines are
attempts to dissuade voters
there's various ways that governments
are now trying to suppress the vote
and one of them is a long line keeping
people from voting
there's too many efforts here to take
away our rights
and to take history backwards
and i'm angered by it i'm really
surprised in myself
that i stayed in the line because when i
was at the end of it
or at the back of it i actually wanted
to get back in my car
we visited multiple polling stations and
almost everyone we spoke to was
suspicious
about the cutbacks in voting locations
and the system hiccups
it's getting more challenging and i'm
like why you know what i'm saying so i
do feel like
there's some suppression a little bit
everyone should matter but we don't as
black americans don't matter
and it's unfortunate that it has to be
that way in
a country that's supposed to be a free
country
[Applause]
there are about a million newly
registered voters
and that's why they're pressing everyone
to get out
and cast their vote because it could
count here in georgia
cause i'm so excited and i'm ready to do
it again and again and again and again
citizens or celebrities they realize how
crucial the votes here
are this probably be one of the most
important elections ever
if i'm honest tell me why because it's a
lot at stake
it's a lot of state we need some changes
and um
this is a lot at stake all the way
around the board
we got to get out here let our voices be
heard so that's why we're here
and in the birthplace of america's civil
rights movement there's a chilling
warning from one of atlanta's most
famous families
the president sometimes acts as if he's
a king or or queen or
a dictator and that's not the way
democracy operates he acts in a fascist
way do you think america is looking at
a threat to democracy here oh no
question
and it's that which is bringing them out
in the peach state
alex crawford sky news atlanta georgia